because
most women if you earn less than them
there's a certain level of respect they
just won't give you and you know what
i'm saying and you're not speaking to me
a certain way in my house not happening
they'll support you for like a period of
time but there are
dynamics that i'm more interested in
like that thought that that kind of
thought like so then respect was of
course there's a certain level of
respect a woman is not going to give you
if she knows she's out early
because she had the money she can get a
lawyer and she can leave i understand
that and i have nothing against that
it's just to be like a woman is leaving
because she's earning more no what's the
reasons why and because she's really is
this hard
okay so but there has to be a disharmony
and that is this army is the fact she's
earning more well but where's the level
of that would it not be because the man
is feeling not necessary about it but
she's leaving her all living
so i've ever so this is what i've seen
and guys i mean from the men's point of
view you can tell me if this is accurate
or inaccurate i found if a girl let's
say a girl gets a promotion she's making
half a million a year is she going to
submit to the guy and say you get to
make all the financial decisions in the
house impossible do you do you guys feel
like most girls that you've dated would
be cool with you being 100 in charge of
the money if they're out earning yeah
a lot of women would be idealistic and
say no i would like i would still like
you to make all the decisions but when
it becomes more practical and she's the
breadwinner the dynamics change really
fast because then she's trying to tell
you mate watch the dishes
that's it
i'm working hella hours and i'm not
going to come home to a dirty kitchen
right now this is gross
it's like most men would say oh if my
wife put on weight after having kids
that i'm going to be with her forever
and never cheat but
when she's looking like 200 pounds
heavier and then your sexy sex tree
comes in you might slip into a vagina by
accident
you're loyal but bro it's the madness
and also yeah like updated women here
that make good money maybe not more than
me but good money and most women don't
like spending money on you anyway so it
don't matter how much you make
i'm not even gonna lie because i always
end up spending the majority of the
money in the relationship regardless
they spend their money on themselves as
many always deployed the idea that your
money is your money as a woman but my
money's out our money yeah that's how it
works see it differently 100 especially
if you come from that kind of upbringing
in it so i always i'll always pay most
of the time so these girls are living
life they're going on holiday with their
friends with the money that they should
be spending on man
you know what i mean
what's she doing on that holiday you
know what i'm saying that
you know you know what i'm saying but
what's up you know better though i do
think that's mental if you have a girl
that's not spending on you and you're
still with her that's that's your
problem what are you going to do run her
down for a pee is that what you're on
i'm sorry if if she's with you and
you're she's not doing anything not
paying for anything at all not even one
day that's on you so what you're sitting
at the table and you're saying to my man
with the chip saying you'll
my birthday my wife doesn't take me out
it's finished yeah but if your head if
you're a nice girl that's actually into
usual often
bro i'm sure i'm sure all of you have
had at some point a girl that that's
obsessed with you
of her not just offering and not
actually doing
it's on you to then be like okay she's
not actually doing this why should i do
the same because that's character what
do you mean by characters that's her
character then so i think it's on the
man but that's what i'm saying women
don't like it yeah i'm agreeing with you
if you're with somebody and that's their
character that they are inherently
selfish
where's the accountability and i picked
a super selfish person but going back to
the five like earning half a meal
is that fair that i would be earning the
half a meal and you get to make all the
decisions of course it's not well not
it's not fair but what the problem is is
when you start leading in a relationship
we're not attracted to a guy that we can
just like that's whipped yes
so i think there's more of a
shared pot
if i'm the breadwinner it goes into a
shared pot i don't think i would turn
over what i'm earning
and then somebody else who isn't earning
the same is like this is how it's being
spent i i understand what she's saying
this is what i'm saying about the
respect thing do you know what i'm
saying this is the thing so actually i
have a question for you so um you said
accountability for picking the wrong
partner
um do you feel the same way about women
that pick cheaters and or abusers yeah
okay so so you you believe it's equal
you're accountable for the people that
you pick yeah yeah yeah it's vibrational
okay
i need to elaborate on that one it's
vibrational i think that after you've
gone through it
when you come out of it
there has to be some type of
accountability i think if you've
actually how do i
how did that happen how did i allow it
to take place what was taking place in
the dynamics of the relationship and i
was there it's still on the person who
did the cheating because they did the
act
but you there is some type of
complicitness to it and if you take the
person back and you stay with them and
they do it again yeah it's your fault i
i agree
do you think most women think that way
no no i actually
okay
no okay outwardly okay
but i think internally they actually
beat themselves up and they do but then
they gain the same situation again so
what does that say because vibrationally
they haven't learned but what do you
mean by voting because they've got
myself
but you need two people that are in
attraction to each other so they are
still in a lack they're still in an
insecurity and the person knows i can do
this to this person because they are not
full of themselves but maybe they just
like the thrill of that because i i one
thing i've noticed a lot with girls is
that you know you'll be of a guy who's a
scammer you'll be a guy who's a drug
dealer and then complain when he scams
you and cheats
oh
a scammer you are a scammer
of course because if you're okay with
him doing that then you're doing it i
know when he stands on you
if you get cheated on it's your own
fault like you picked up it definitely
it should be that way but this is where
i see the problem with self-awareness in
a modern society a lot of people claim
to be self-aware and understand
themselves but they really they don't if
you're making those decisions and then
complaining about the outcome of those
decisions it doesn't make sense so a lot
of girls look for avenues to absolve
themselves the responsibility of the
problems that they create one of them is
western western horoscopes ah you know
your star sign is this so he's an area
i'm saying yeah i'm a hearing so it goes
back to that idea of accountabilities
like women are never told no or
or held accountable in the sense that
you've got to grow as an individual to
get to to grow out of this
yeah yeah they don't have to
self-develop because but if they look
good someone else will pick them up in
it but i think i think there's a growing
population of men that are the exact
same you know they don't take
accountability for the things they're
doing you know
it might be because exactly becoming
more feminine it's the same thing a guy
will go for girls that um you know only
wants them for money and they'd be
complaining that girls only won them for
money
it doesn't make sense i don't know about
that one
i've seen i've seen a lot of guys come
back guys guys with money don't complain
about spending but that's the thing it's
only broke brother
you've got broke friends i hear it but
um
will never complain that i'm spending
money on a girl no because they know
they know what it is they know it's
transactional anyway but it depends on
what you want so again if you're trying
to look for marriage you don't want a
girl that's just taking you for money no
it doesn't make sense most men won't
care if you as long as
if you got money and she's pretty more
time you're going to ignore a lot of the
bad characteristics so you don't have to
deal with them see you all you have to
deal with those when you're when when
you're an average guy with a with a girl
that's
women are naturally hypergamous
there's a lot more wiggle room for her
to push limits when you're a guy with
money you can just tell it to shut up
and i think it depends on how you got
your money because there is a difference
between a successful man and a higher
value man yes i in my job i work with
rich people every single day
like hedge fund managers or partners in
firms
their wants are very different how many
how many how many divorces have most of
the guys
cap
it's not a lot divorce is the less the
richer man is exactly right they've also
left
they want different things you know a
man who's successful because he's a
rapper or a singer yeah these different
things that are only successful because
he he he
i think that's down to the fact that the
woman sees that what that she's found a
resource that she can't let go of but so
she doesn't act in a way that a woman
with less than would act but not
necessarily because